we'll have a talk that that involves
tech
ecology that is very much rooted into
the in the 20th century
of course semiconductors displacing
vacuum tubes would still be a 20th
century technology perhaps we will have
those quantum computers at some point
but I'm not talking about information
technology per se this is energy
conversion so it's a very simple concept
there's no controversial physics there
are quantum mechanical effects and some
interesting heat transfer effects that
have been that would require a more
modern approach but it's the centenary
areas this year and I really enjoy the
history of science so I'm going to
inject that there's also some political
history that affected this field and
through the through the 20th century it
attracted billions of dollars of
investment not from private capital
generally it was government's working on
this for various purposes it is not a
Tomine no knowledge used today but
there's been an effort to revive it over
the past decade and that would have
started at Stanford and it didn't start
with me I think it's interesting there's
an interesting question that how did it
get started and what what we're working
on is wafer scale fabrication listen you
know lithography atching but impossibly
in fact much more modern techniques to
nano structure surfaces and materials
that didn't exist if you can go do a
Google Scholar search on my name a
recent publication in nano letters
should come up in a project with my
student and several faculty and other
students looking at an anode with a very
low work function motivated by this the
anode material is graphene something
that wasn't a 20th century material I
remember graphite and pencils some
people may remember not the Apple one on
the new iPad so what what what are we
going to do applying this and
essentially reinventing the
simple concept in a way that is
potentially cost-effective and could
have many applications and when you
think of my field of MEMS there's whole
conferences on energy scavenging for
Internet of Things getting rid of
batteries but this is primary energy
conversion that would be targeting watts
to megawatts depending on the scale
we may need quite a few wafers to do
that so what applications I'll go
through three of them and the third one
would be a major focus of efforts in
Germany and finally I think there's a
lot of research prospects there's also
been a startup out of the group that is
a couple of PhD students teaming up over
the summer so thermionic emission can be
understood as from a view of a lake on a
summer day you have essentially a vapor
coming off there's a vapor pressure of
water it's visible in this case and the
same thing happens in a metal if you
heat it hot enough you start having
things come up ultimately the metal
begins to vaporize but in our case we
aren't going that hot we're just
interested in getting electrons off so
if you remember you don't really need to
understand too much solid-state physics
we have a Fermi level at Absolute Zero
all the states are filled up and we're
certainly not after Absolute Zero
temperatures in the hundreds or even
1500 degrees centigrade okay we need a
very high source of heat or we need a
new material with a much lower work
function
what do we then do well we collect those
electrons we boil them off and this is a
thermionic diode energy converter which
has been the most focus of the Stanford
work that I've been involved with and
those electrons are collected this is
kind of an artistic energy diagram
showing that the anode has a different
work function and it's probably cooler
and there are words of emitter-collector
anode and cathode and and
the letter C would be on the wrong side
in between these but emission and
collection and if you look at our papers
we would use these interchangeably so
the anode and cathode emitter anode
collector and the physics are very well
understood you have an output voltage
that's a difference of work functions
there's actually that's an idealized
case there are probably some barriers in
there that would involve things that
space charge and other kinds of energy
barriers that would reduce that voltage
work function differences are around the
order of a volt and depending on the
temperature this exponential will get
you a tremendous current density so you
would have high current low voltage very
similar to a photovoltaic cell in terms
of how we deal with it the physics of
the emission is the Richardson Dutchman
law it would be nice to have a large
difference and the there's a design that
would depend on the temperature of the
heat source what work function unit on
the emitter but certainly going low on
the anode is a good idea that's been an
effort in our group there would be
issues of heat transfer you have
possibly a very narrow gap probably in a
vacuum and you could imagine radiative
and other sources of heat especially
since you ultimately are going to be
getting electricity out you have wires
on this and you have heat losses through
the wires so it's a very simple idea you
should be able to get some energy out in
and that is indeed the case Edison is
the coiner of the the word thermians he
was looking at the incandescent light
bulb and he was studying the decay of
the filament and he put a something in
there he was trying to collect soot but
instead he got current and and so since
it was a hot thing he coined that word
in the 80s and of the 19th century you
have Richardson
his contributions that led to a Nobel
Prize you have a guy a slicker in World
War one and the appendix of his PhD in
physics at Tubingen proposes a
thermionic converter because he's doing
Richardson Dutchman experiments on
different materials and he makes the
proposal in 1915 and then in the
actually the first practical one the
demonstration was 1939 in the Soviet
Union another not so good year in in
Europe 1915 in 1939 but in the
post-world War two ERA you have a huge
investment in the US and the Soviet
Union one breakthrough was a guy who
just passed away at nearly a hundred
turn quest at at RCA had a litt diode he
struck a plasma to deal with space
charge effects that paid a price for
that and caesium is not the easiest
material to work with but this was
actually something that was efficient
efficient enough to attract a lot of
investment so 1973 I'm in late junior
high school locally and a lot of things
happening in the world that was a long
time ago so I would like to pause and
look at something that the I Triple E in
my field doesn't do they transcribed
discussion sections at conferences and
in fact we not only don't transcribe
them we discourage any recording
whatsoever partly because we always have
a keg at for the audience and the
participants and a lot of discussions
you don't want to you know there could
be things said that might not really
make sense or be coherent in those days
you had people like Hass topless who
ended up on the MIT faculty making
comments of of what they were achieving
in 1968 now 1968 was the peak of the
space race and that was one of the
things that was driving this and they
had a lot of money and they were getting
a lot of progress 20 watts per square
centimeter efficiencies of 15%
they were extrapolating to 30%
heat to electricity the issue from the
NASA perspective was okay we're there
we've got to launch these okay and so
you know ruggedness reliability is a
very important part and in fact the
Atomic Energy Commission representative
on this panel said that don't bother the
power source was a nuclear pile they had
a lot of heat and 15 percent is fine why
bother going further okay so this was
the the atmosphere and the driver and in
fact people did some cool things even
earlier in the 60s you have these
so-called we call them button thermionic
converters they're rather small you see
in this black-and-white photo a little
butane torch on a thermionic converter a
couple of wires and you're running a fan
efficiency around four and a half
percent and the very simple and note no
cesium in there no work function
lowering and that would just be a photo
out a great publicity photo by GE
Research so what happened well the
application here was space power we were
in a race to the moon and elsewhere
there was a lot going on trying to get
long deep space missions and substantial
amounts of power in orbit more than what
the solar cells could provide and
possibly on the dark side of the earth
Soviets actually pushed further they got
a six kilowatt converter and flew it at
the end of the Cold War on a naval
reconnaissance satellite successfully
and after the USSR I don't think this
there are a lot of things that
contributed to the collapse of the USSR
I don't think these converters were
significant but what the cost was I
don't think they had good accounting of
what the effort was to build these
things but it was certainly bleeding
edge technology and not really
manufacturer
we leased a bunch of them at the end of
the Cold War and ended up flying them to
New Mexico on a large transport plane
this is a picture of what it's in the
perspective to have the Soviet
technology show up in New Mexico it's
kind of like a Klingon warship landing
in a federation planet and you're
getting and then actually they give you
their reactor something you get to you
know yes so they built a two-story
vacuum chamber for this no nuclear power
they built optical heating and ran and
tested this and met the guy that was in
charge of that there were reports
written that are not really easily found
on the web and that apparently exists in
libraries they were not you know we were
coming and sharing what their tests were
but these were functioning devices that
did survive the launch this is not
terrestrial technology there is a lot of
precision machining lots of tungsten
lots of cesium and it was a plasma diode
so what happened along the way would
involve politics we have in the u.s. not
the collapse of the country but Nixon
decides space nuclear reactors are
possibly something that can't be
afforded in the post-vietnam era we have
the oil crisis and we have a revival of
alternative energy sources including a
burst in thermionic funding often linked
to again space the some people remember
Star Wars the idea of shooting down
ICBMs from space this is a way to put
nuclear reactors up there and get lots
of power
this isn't Silicon Valley Bill Clinton's
elected
no more star wars ok the thermionic
skies are along for the ride
and there is a bunch of companies that
are sort of trying to navigate through
this and finally an organization you may
or may not have heard of called ditra
the defense Threat Reduction agency has
a report on the web and they concluded
that there wasn't any
short-term path between all this
investment in space military thermionic
sand something that would be useful in
this post Cold War era and they've been
provoked to do this by some people at
Sandia who objected to that but the this
report helped put a wet damper on things
so that was before where were some of
the audience in 2001 kindergarten or
that's a long time ago so what I would
like to do is look at the thermionic
converters I'll revisit that historical
theme sometimes fields are developed and
go on the shelf for various reasons
those I've been on committees with
reports of that sort National Academies
and you've got to be careful on in what
you say in those reports because you you
could be spectacularly wrong in any
event the the cathode work function is
designed around the hot side temperature
they're different sources of heat I'll
mention some completely green ones
concentrated solar there would be not so
green ones that might this might help in
terms of efficiency and there's a sort
of 700 Kelvin times the work function in
electron volts so 1700 Kelvin
you know you subtract roughly 300 is a
hot flame you know that that torch and
so you have a work function around
two-and-a-half electron volts that's
rather easily achieved the anode at one
and a half is not so easily achieved we
there the and I'll mention where we are
in that there's a voltage in the gap
that can be space charge and other
regions that doesn't help and remember
of course you may they're thinking I
have field emission and all but we're
not applying energy to this to
manipulate things we are just sitting
there and going heat to electricity so
the the goal ultimately is getting this
DC power out we have certainly
considered pulsing electrodes and
playing games and that that's something
again that's a 21st century thing so
what do they look like if you look at
the basic important things important
things well typical historical converter
you really don't get a whole lot of
efficiency until you get tremendously
hot cathodes because you have a barrier
index of around two electron volts
remember that's the sum of some of the
anode work function and some gap voltage
if you begin to work on that things get
kind of interesting in terms of lower
temperatures and higher conversion
efficiency and certainly if you get to
around 1/2 electron volt you begin to be
able to look at very nice efficiencies
that would be very useful in a lot of
applications especially if you have a
cold side temperature that's hot enough
to run another cycle so as a topping
cycle is where this could be quite
useful so this is adapted from work by
hosta palos and gift top allows a couple
of obviously Greek a engineering process
at MIT in the in the 70s and thermal
electrics are much more studied huge
investment in thermal electrics for
those who know thermoelectric ZT of 10
is outrageous right people sweat bullets
to get Z T of like 2 + or less and so
also the materials in thermal electrics
have great difficulty at very high
temperatures so the vacuum gap and these
very simple materials tends to mean that
thermionic s' gets into a position of
potentially higher efficiency if you
have the high heat source and so
ultimately you're competitive with these
well developed technologies or an assist
to that in some cases so my argument has
been that we have something that's well
worth looking at I'm not interested if
it's a million-dollar gizmo though NASA
could use it perhaps to get more power
out at Pluto you know you could ride to
Pluto with a nuclear pile the materials
issues of hugging a nuclear pile are
also Syria where serious impediments to
the people working on this right that
they had things to deal with that
we're very challenging I give a talk on
this at a
fusion Research Center in China in the
spring and it's a different kind of
radiation and they would view this as
yet another way to boost you know if
once they get positive this is a way to
get the better efficiency out of a
fusion reactor this is a long-term
project that's going to be not one group
it's going to take a major commitment to
make this happen it's wonderful to visit
the fusion people who look at it even
longer drive into mid-century they're
people whose whole career will be
working in fusion and just to indicate
the effort they were busy trying to
deliver something to San Diego because
China and the Verret Japan and Europe
there's an international testbed in San
Diego and efforts to get that moving
further along this this could help I've
never seen a tokamak up close it is
quite a quite a machine so how to do
wafers wafer scale thermionic swell not
invented here this is Don King who was
testing the tokamaks there's a huge
effort in MEMS at Sandia in the 90s he
wasn't personally involved but I think
he read the you know Sandia is a big lab
but I think people are unaware of what's
happening it's always important to be
aware of what your colleagues are doing
in different parts of the university
just there's some grad students that can
actually be disruptive so Don filed a
patent and tried to get funding on
basically something that would look like
an early accelerometer deep reactive ion
etching silicon bonded together he did
some theory that said if you got a
micron gap you should be able to get 30%
no plasma needed because you're too
close the space charge can't form so
there's some physics that work he got
the patent issued it took a while and it
was filed not too long after the topaz's
showed up I think when you have someone
you know especially at Sandia pushing
for a significant program that I think
triggered I don't know the exact causal
relationship but the this committee
looked at this micro thermionic
converter proposal and said that
basically
there was a need for this tremendous
temperature gradient 500 thousand Kelvin
per millimeter interesting units you'd
think it would be five hundred Kelvin
per micron which is possibly challenging
I think it's more than that
the committee said that that sustaining
such an enormous temperature gradient
with tolerable material you know thermal
conduction losses is not credible you
have a thermal short-circuit okay and I
can see signing off on that and the
these were the ditra people from the
defense Threat Reduction agency that you
can download it it's a public report in
fact there were no people from my field
on it because long before this there had
been something called a bolometer
invented various places is incredibly
thermally isolated structure that would
detect millikelvin temperatures and yet
be anchored to a substrate so the
thermal isolation for this in order to
make an infrared camera out of an array
of these and there's a big push to get
these into automobiles that would
involve you'll find my name but mostly
Tom Kenny and mechanical engineering
would be doing atomic layer deposition
for incredibly thin bolometer x'
structures this is vanadium oxide a very
difficult material and the goal is to
get them cheap enough that every car
would have a heads-up display with an
infrared camera my community is pushing
hard so that there's something you may
not know I'm injecting from planet MEMS
in the Allen building we would lose half
of our night vision by the age of 40 and
I don't know what the full curve is but
it is not in the favor of people driving
at night and of course we've driven a
lot so we can edit in we know what
should be on 280 we don't necessarily
see the deer or the people working on
their flat tire or something and to have
that highlighted on on the right
heads-up would save a lot of lives
including the animals and the people who
roll trying to avoid the animals so in
any event this is a major thing they
should have known about this we can
detect millikelvin
and so what do you do well we want Killa
Kelvin not millikelvin but it's the same
basic structure and this is a simulation
and console by Expo stocky or Margit and
X PhD student Jay Lee and you see
temperatures of 1400 Kelvin and
basically room temperature on the
anchors because you have something that
is thermally floated off the surface it
has long legs and they're hot in the
center and they there's a big thermal
gradient now will it move out of plane
you know there's some interesting
engineering we made you trough
suspensions to make it stiff out of
plane can't make eye beams easily but we
can make you beams and those are very
stiff even though it's made out of a
very thin film so in any case it looks
like it work will it work well we made
something out of a material it's not a
very good cathode but it's a good
platform this is silicon carbide lpcvd
sölden carbide it wasn't done in the
Stanford Nanofab because we don't have a
silicon carbide tube but it is available
in Berkeley so this grad student went up
there and you have this structure that
certainly suboptimal the lithography
isn't great but it certainly is
thermally isolated and we optically
heated it so there's a series of things
where this is in a vacuum chamber where
we're looking through kind of a
telescope to see this little pixel
that's getting hotter and hotter and
hotter and hotter and it gets cooler and
cooler it doesn't care the substrates
basically room temperature and you're
heating this to outrageous temperatures
well over 2,000 centigrade and
incandescent so the whole ditra
committee i haven't contacted but of
course their cover story is they put
that in there to provoke people right
that you know i mean it's obviously
idiotic comment and they wanted someone
to you know rise to the challenge that's
if you're ever on a committee you can
always say that you you knew better yeah
yeah yeah so it gets you know we were
able with a blue laser you know if
Sillman carbide has a high band gap but
we were able to get energy into it just
to demonstrate the thermal isolation
that isn't a thermionic cathode you
need to do more than that but it is a
start that was a few years ago so one
question is we can easily fabricate gaps
from 100 nanometers and maybe even
thinner to 100 microns it gets harder if
in micro fab wood wafer bonding that's
kind of the easy sweet spot do we want
to make large gaps no if a - if it's
hundred microns you're going to get
space charge you're gonna get charge
buildup across this gap it's well-known
from vacuum tube days when your child
wha if you get really small that looked
kind of attractive but lately people
have been looking at heat transfer in
tiny tiny gaps and it turns out you get
coupling between surfaces through the
vacuum it's kind of evanescent heat
transfer and so there's an Applied
Physics letter that looked at this and
there's a lot of things that happen when
you get close you can have photons that
reflect but then couple to the other
side if you're in a close enough gap and
you get heat across you can have near
field perturbations all kinds of
different things that we modeled and
borrowed models from the community to
see what the the optimum would be well
normally in engineering Murphy says the
optimum is inconvenient just on
principle in this case he's asleep
because in fact the optimal is exactly
where we would want to be in your pocket
would be much more lavish laborat
silicon gyroscopes and accelerometers
with massive numbers of comb fingers and
spacings that are all in the range of a
micron and and so this was like
excellent news the efficiency it's all
you know sixty percent is a idealized 1d
model it's the area where we want to
operate we don't want to be where the
Russians were which was over here at a
hundred microns losing a lot of fishin
sea to space charge and having to do a
plasma not really recovering it and if
we get really close then we out also get
thermal shorting so that I think was a
contribution to set the rule so lately
bleurgh now at Microsoft Justin's doing
a startup and and I decided to make a
cathode for the sole purpose of actually
testing anode so it was a
second-generation process where we would
have holes to the backside for
convenient optical heating and so this
shows a typical process layers and
lithography but it's not electronics
it's MEMS so things are a bit larger and
we're going to make a composite of
tungsten and silicon carbide on the
cathode because silicon carbide doesn't
have the right bandgap and tungsten is a
standard well-known cathode material so
what actually looks like is kind of cool
if you're into 3d micromachining there's
a hole underneath that wasn't quite
perfectly aligned you can kind of see
and we have this grid structure where we
would put the tungsten and then this
surface coatings of like barium
strontium to lower the work function
further and we would deposit those
coatings using an atomic layer
deposition not the kind of old-school
mortar and pestle kind of technique so
you would have something that you could
crank out a huge number amounts of this
we haven't dense packed the pixels or
anything in fact if you no MEMS you
probably want another layer to have like
the DIA that Texas Instruments mirror
display would be an example of a
two-level device with a tremendous fill
factor and with a single layer you can't
do two too much so so any event we've
built these for the sole purpose of
testing where we're focused and lately
has been on the anode and I'll tell you
we is a lot more than my group on this
this is a commercial dispenser cathode
one of our test anodes on a heater stage
all of this goes into quite an
interesting vacuum system in the more
building in the jabal lab for advanced
materials and Nick melash has built this
vacuum thing and here it is in there
running you know it's basic materials
research to try to see how this anode is
going to work this is going to take a
long time if we are building this in an
edisonian way
it and in fact one of the things that's
happened in the 21st century is
computation this is a student Sharron
Chao X student she's PhD had a PhD in
which she looked at these complex
mixtures of things that you would coat
to lower the work function there's
barium strontium calcium and
historically mixed up things very very
complicated physics and how do you
optimize this without doing hundreds of
experiments and having a decade-long PhD
well there wasn't much of a choice
in fact in a polycrystalline case you've
got a lot of complex material transport
and the electrons and getting out of
here what I'm just going to click
through this because the shortcut is to
compute it and density functional theory
is a standard way to from first
principles not perfectly but rather
computationally efficient sufficiently
you can get the work function you get
formation energy and so with her diving
in with yen's nor scoff in chemical
engineering and a group at slack I was
able to gear up on this and adapt some
code and end up using DFT and and
there's some you know feedback loop of
optimizing the pseudo potentials and all
there's some front work that's needed
but once you've got the Machine set up
you are in business to do a whole bunch
of calculations of work function and a
proxy for formation energy so these are
triangular diagrams of mixtures of
barium oxide calcium oxide strontium
oxide and additional materials that
would additional sort of dopants lithium
and scandium you know complex thing this
is all computed not measured and in fact
you have both of these and 570 total
composition
this is a paper and Journal of physical
chemistry and the people doing this all
of a sudden you have an arrow that says
we you know go try here first right we
don't we haven't mapped all of this we
do have some literature that in selected
parts of this space but I think this is
an example why it's good to be doing
your PhD in 2015
those of us who are doing PhDs in
earlier in an earlier millennium wished
we could have computed our way to
accelerated experiments and actually get
a paper along the way it doesn't get any
better but in many cases it was nothing
but going in and and grappling with
things one step at a time I think a
really big Braith breakthrough Sharon
was second author on a paper with a
Johannes Voss how many of you been to
slack I'm talking to the younger
generation well no it's okay but
prostitutes and all they're there are
tremendous possibilities at slack that
would include you know computer science
in EE more than you might think just end
of story and this in this case you have
a bunch of people Johannes had the idea
that he could cleverly extend the
boundary conditions including the leads
and compute the emission current for the
first time for the very first time from
first principles compute the Richardson
Dutchman coefficient and I think as we
have envisioned new materials you now
have a platform where you can compute
work function and the emission current
and so with some serious attention and
and of course it's nice to have one of
these computing clusters at SLAC that
has a lot of cores thousands and
thousands and we put them to good use so
in any case where are we collectively
cathodes are not the big problem
tungsten and with the Ald deposited Nano
laminate from Sharon's PhD we can get to
one-and-a-half evie if we want to or we
could in some cases we don't need to go
that low there's been a lot of work at
Vanderbilt and nano crystalline diamond
and the Richardson Dutchman coefficient
however has to be very high it's not
enough to have a low work function and a
very low emission as possible diamond
has been very difficult there bright
spots on the on the surface and a lot of
it doesn't emit at all so a node is a
harder problem Neman achat arizona state
has a nitrogen doped nano crystalline
diamond with 0.9 electron volts that is
very attractive he is well aware of the
thermionic implications of that
so remember 0.5 is like a Holy Grail 0.9
isn't bad and Dan Riley filed his thesis
in June he has a point 7 but it's a
surface photo voltage effect on some
some very surface engineered
semiconductor and I'll mention
semiconductors playing a role in in
potentially the cathode as well and I
actually that nano letter is and I don't
have slides on it because it just
published was the electrostatically
doped graphene where we use a field to
pull down the work function and we got
to 1e v with graphene so that is a
potential anode as well so new materials
make things much better how do you
vacuum encapsulate these things actually
that was a big problem for MEMS if you
want to make a good resonator clock if
you want to make a gyro you want to have
it in a vacuum people know how to do
vacuum but do they new know how to do
vacuum at the wafer level in high volume
well Jay decided to and we had a visitor
from Japan we did old-school glass to
silicon wafer bonding to seal up some
cathodes and see if we could run them
and it kind of a demo and yes the vacuum
wasn't ideal for this but we have under
glass a an encapsulated structure the
gyros in your phone are absolutely eight
inch wafer going to 12 inch wafer wafer
to wafer bonded
sealed and and produced in a commodity
in this case we have to be careful
there's high temperature seals we have
to seal ideally on the anode side where
it's not so hot there's certainly some
materials that would be needed in the
60s there there there are people around
who were there in the development of
thermionic they said the vacuum seals
were a major problem once they got them
fixed the reliability was not an issue
so we would have some input from the the
early technology now in much of my
career the core device is always
wonderful but if you pan out you have
wires and interconnects our
interconnects and contacts or the bane
of everything and so are we actually
having something that's great but you
can't actually get any current out well
it's nice that other people are trying
to go to very high temperatures the EU
has had a big project on high
temperature gas servent gas turbine
sensing and we have a colleague Debbie
Sandusky and Aero and Astro who is very
motivated by Aeryn Astro applications
where MEMS sensors have to go to
outrageously high temperatures so here's
an example of a indium aluminium nitride
hampt that's been running at 800 degrees
my students sometimes anneal things and
furnaces at 800 this thing's operating
at 800 and it has a very modest an alum
copper ohmic contact I don't show the
one in this electrochemical Society
paper where they had the the
metallization was screwed up and didn't
work it was completely destroyed at
operating at that temperature so
actually these materials could be it
could be not so much of a problem I
would point to a collaborator at
Berkeley Roy and LaBute Ian and her
student Fang Lu they looked at a contact
that would use a new type of nano
graphic carbon between silicon carbide
and platinum and their contact
really the limit of their furnace is 540
degrees and the normal contact is
beginning to fail but what's really
shocking recently is that they would run
this in air and so it's not in a vacuum
at all it's a very you know things are
oxidizing and hundreds and hundreds of
centigrade this the carbon is not
susceptible to that they've sort of
demonstrated I think we can get the the
current out so a lot of pieces and in in
and you know if we really put it
together yet well I will tell you more
when we wrap up what are the commercial
applications where this could work
jacy's Shao is that Department of Energy
and is this is a 2008 version of a chart
that would show sort of cost versus
capacity in kilowatts and also
efficiency and some of our favorite
things like gas turbines are quite good
if you are powering a small city not so
good if you want to get energy that
would be at a smaller level mit had a
micro turbine project but Micro is
relative and they are certainly going to
have challenges in this 1 to 10 watt
range so we think there could be small
scale applications the ones on the right
we possibly could add on top of that
extra efficiency and I'll mention some
of those applications as well so where
will this possibly be useful there's a
lot of heat in the world sometimes we go
to great lengths to heat things to very
high temperature we should consider
insulation as a as a scavenger right we
can be insulating and pulling energy out
the humble water heater the Department
of Energy would like to turn into a
cogent plant if you could do something
better than the kind of cogent that
would involve reciprocating engines and
so we would be nice to get a kilowatt
out of your water heater
and that isn't perfectly green because
you would get it by burning more natural
gas but it would have a net our RPE has
published what the impact of that would
be they had a call for proposals that
that would have a pocketbook impact on
the person or apartment owned or you
know individual house or apartment and
it would reduce carbon emissions and
it's just an all around when it's not
perfect but you would use that flame in
the back east and the winter you're you
know you could be running that all the
time the waste heat of course is your
hot water and right now you're only
making water hotter a hot water so it's
a distributed power solution some people
are obsessed with efficiency and
certainly these are designed in a way
that opt is optimum modern air aircraft
I think the 787 was called the first
really electric airplane getting rid of
a lot of hydraulics so there are
generators on those planes on those
engines that are producing tremendous
amounts of power again a thermionic
converter could change the way you
design the combustor and the entire
engine if you're getting significant
power out of the hot zone so a and of
course we have our concentrated solar
where there's no shortage of high
temperature and a real incentive to
boost the efficiency of those plants
there's existing heat engines but the
temperature on that surface of that
graphite which is actually black at in
without illumination but is heated to
well over the temperature that you can
use in a normal heat engine so the
thermionic s-- converter would take the
the concentrated heat at the surface and
the reject temperature would be able to
run the rest of the you know converter
so so in any case how does a water
heater produce electricity well you have
thermionic converters in the burners and
and I guess since these are in a closet
or in the garage it's nice that there
aren't reciprocating engines with ma
all of this you do have exhaust coming
out the target efficiency is not so high
the record thermionic converters 22%
okay if you get to around 25% it becomes
very attractive to do this and the
Cornell did a study on the Oh on the
impact of super-aggressive conversion to
natural gas
leading to a non-fossil future versus
cold turkey going to the non-fossil
future they're almost the same so this
could be a bridge that would buy some
time to get the the the more green
solutions perfected in Europe
Jochen Manhart gave a talk over the
summer that was actually standing room
only in material science on their
thermionic converter project which
actually has a Stanford connection this
is a triode you have an emitter
collector and a gate they proposed using
electromagnetic fields to stabilize the
electrons so they aren't intercepted by
the gate a lot of elegant enm they have
a paper last month in a APL materials on
using graphene as the gate pattern
graphene they've measured the
transparency of graphene to low energy
electrons and it's about 60% first time
that's measured and very low energy
electrons and they have apertures in it
so again a new material could be a
game-changer in terms of allowing you to
build something that would otherwise not
be so efficient in this paper which is a
couple years old I took this from
yokum's site he was using a laser etched
a kind of milli scale grid and so the
target in Germany is coal-fired not not
natural gas or oil coal-fired plants
there's a lot of them in Europe and this
would be the topping cycle that would
make them more efficient until they're
ultimately turned off but that may be a
while and so that could be a driving
application
I think the our focus has been
ultimately on small-scale applications
where we you know we think something on
the order of a hundred watts to a
kilowatt would be much more attractive
what would you do with a hundred watts
I'll mention in in a minute that that's
kind of a that's like your laptop
battery with full on calculation why
would you want to just use a battery Oh
expound on that a little bit but but
what's interesting is there is a soviet
stanford connection that actually
motivated my getting into this the
thermionic diodes and trials at max
planck and the work in my group and nick
milosh is in cxas sections group all
derived from a paper in 2005 by BY
Moises and th jabal okay and it was a
proposal for a new kind of thermionic
converter a theory paper in the journal
of physics d and who were these people
well
Boris passed away just three years after
that at a very old age he was the head
of the Soviet thermionic program he got
out of the Soviet Union after the Cold
War collapsed and he went to McCulloch
building at Stanford to be a research
associate with Ted Jamaal who's actually
still around I sat next to him in the
standing room only talk I knew about it
ahead of time my students were all you
know plastered around the periphery and
Ted is very much into thermionic snow
thanks to Boris and one of the things
that would be interesting is to see a US
patent application involving the Germans
at Max Planck and the lead guy Ted who
retired a while ago in fact Glam the
jabal lab of event for advanced
materials is named after him but he has
an office in McCulloch and would be
interested in the triode since he's
contributed to that so this is not
necessarily wafer scale technology but
it is as
someone interested in the history of
science that is a to me a fascinating
proposition so fascinating historical
connection and we've looked up
conferences where of course it's in
Cyrillic it's in Russian headed by Boris
and in the 70s so 21st century
application if you look in Spain there's
the original grid qualified solar plant
now these are very large installations
that's a very large tower and lately
they've been doing storage by heating
molten salts and running turbines at
night at a reduced load so this is
always giving power to the grid more
interesting locally outside of Las Vegas
just in the California side of the
california/nevada border in a place that
has almost no one there I don't know why
Ivanpah I don't know if there are any
residents there but there's a 200 plus
megawatt solar concentrated solar plant
that would have these big towers and in
fact the people that design this bright
source is a company up in Oakland they
are only wondering whether thermionic is
a 2020 or 2030 kind of technology in our
one of our papers we estimated that you
would basically be at coal cost for
generation if you could add a really
optimized thermionic boost to this so
they are very much interested in that so
lastly I'd like to look at some really
radical innovations that that have come
out of Nick milosh Nick Milosh now I
didn't make the connection when I got
into it but there's an former colleague
of ours
Peter pumas and I put in a proposal to
this after seeing Ted's paper Peters now
at iMac and so that was circa 2007 or so
and actually Nick I emailed him because
I knew he'd done some cool diamond work
and I thought diamond might be good for
thermionic so typical faculty we go meet
to our meeting have a blast and he
convinces us diamond isn't ready because
not only
do the other diamond guys understand he
doesn't understand it it's a lot of
things with diamond that are really cool
but not really ready for a device for EE
kind of applications well that night
after that meeting in March from 2008 he
goes home and being significantly
younger I think kids toddlers get put to
bed and then I get this email at 3
o'clock in the morning and it's this
very long email where he proposes using
a semiconductor instead of a metal now
having taught with Jim Harris EE 2:16
these kinds of band diagrams and why on
earth did wasn't this thought of
sometimes you know the most obvious
thing is sitting right in front of you
it's rather complicated physics it's not
a photo cathode
it's a photon assisted thermionic
process and there's a nature materials
paper that goes into the details of this
process where you have to only get over
the electron affinity so it could run a
lot cooler that that you don't have to
go all the way into that from the p-type
the Fermi level up because you can get
partially boosted into the conduction
band you need light for this straight
thermionic saz we call the the thing
that you put in your water heater
doesn't need the photons but in that
concentrated solar you know plenty of
photons and the heat so can you you have
an opportunity to design something that
could boost the temperature tremendously
and it loves to be hot you need the heat
to get over it's not a photovoltaic cell
remember it is a vacuum gap Dan Reilly's
PhD and put a semiconductor on the anode
so the whole thing is is now part of
semiconductor physics and has to be
added if this really flies and and it
can drop the anode work function and
change the operating mode what a what
would happen then in a in a solar plan
is that you have this concentrated solar
flux that has a thermionic layer on top
and the back end is the same old good
old steam run
turban that they would have already and
so it's just stay if it doesn't work it
doesn't not much changes right but if it
is working and you're getting
electricity out of this hot zone you
have things in series and in if you're
even a 25% in unlike computing where you
have to get factors in order to make any
impact at all this could be quite
interesting there are a lot of materials
challenges Jared got his PhD on the
topic in December of last year so what
are the research prospects for this I
think it's very attractive I would be
kind of an enthusiast you know you get
bitten by different things and there's a
whole lot of objections I was early into
MEMS and there was huge amount of
objections of things that would never
work and you know all kinds of reasons
not to do this and I kind of have seen
that kind of you know but I can see it's
hard but it certainly is global and the
payoff could be quite huge the use of
photons could be quite attractive in the
for concentrated solar and and it
actually makes some things easier the
temperatures can drop because you have
less of a barrier but we know a whole
lot more about materials processes than
in the past and I think that a hundred
years after the invention there's a
chance of running the the bright source
people need a thousand square meters of
thermionic converters that would be
built in some kind of a hexagonal tile
certainly ceramic frames not a hundred
percent fill factor but we know how kind
of know how to do this sort of thing and
if you estimate the cost it is of course
quite affordable because we're very good
at lithography and and wafer bonding and
things so I'd like to hitchhike on to my
MEMS efforts and and also import the
nano world's things so who's working on
this locally and beyond we have one of
the collaborators Jim he's contributed
through the MBE two papers on the on the
peat
and the the semiconductor anode yen's is
a chemi
but he's also at slack as one of the
great computational materials people
piripi Aneta is that slack and he eat
the beam line at SSR SSR l has been
effective ZX is an amazing renaissance
physicist applied physicists material
science as former chief scientist of
slack has contributed NIC massively Roy
at Berkeley as a surface science and
silicon carbide and we've gotten
collaborations with Jim's former student
at UT Austin building materials and NREL
mile Steiner has some good growth
furnaces so in any case it's a an
interesting kind of effort to shake the
tree with some new ideas and see if we
can kick this off so the students
involved a lot of them are no longer
around and I haven't put up the the new
ones and the new ones did not make this
talk because we actually have a group
meeting tomorrow and I think they have
other things to do then here the the the
review but Igor is that you Penn he was
a born in Siberia Moscow State undergrad
Caltech PhD in physics who I think my
role is to sort of make him an engineer
and he would be doing a lot of
interesting materials in MA at Penn Jay
Lee teamed up with a student of Krishna
Saraswat and has founded an infrared
imaging company called straw do I think
they've moved recently to San Francisco
Sharon is doing software for energy at
first fuel in the Boston area
and Justins in a start-up Blair
Microsoft Hong yuan is a lead author on
that paper on the graphene anode and Jay
Provine is a senior research associate
who is in frits Prince's group mostly
now so I mentioned the startup and then
so they these couple of guys are not
visible in here Nixon group goes
whitewater rafting that's a bit dated
picture because there's actually
water in a river in California you have
to carry the boat downstream dan and
Jared teamed up on something that was
called m37
out of Lawrence Berkeley National Lab
it's now called cyclotron Road it's an
idea that energy startups are not like
app startups you need patience and you
need to trennis resources so they're
kind of incubated at a National Lab and
there's four other little companies you
can read about them in the New York
Times and you can go to their website
they're trying to commercialize
thermionic sand have picked the name
spark thermionic so two physicists who
actually have rubbed shoulders with
material scientists and E's and I think
it's will be interesting to see how
things go so with that I'd like to
acknowledge the funding agencies okay
I'm gonna click through them all because
as you can imagine to restart something
take some effort right so you would see
gee SEP is a critically important at
Stanford historically for energy the
global climate and energy project I had
a DARPA Center with companies involved
that were very interested in this it was
a I say was because it ended a couple of
years ago kind of a cost share matching
thing
DARPA DSO has been interested for
small-scale photon enhanced thermionic
s-- the application you have an
inflatable concentrator mirror in your
backpack in the Sierras
you have a small thermionic converter
that gives enough juice like 500 Watts
so you can run a cappuccino machine
which has to be light weighted and that
is a application that could attract some
interest from the community bring power
very light lightweight and no fossil
fuels and doesn't work at night but that
may be okay so in any case the more
foundation-funded CX Department of
Energy has begun to get interested and
this has all been made in the mostly in
the SNF somewhat in Burke
late and with that I think I am out of
time and also open for questions there's
this goes for another 15 minutes right
which is which it means that I was out
of time because I thought maybe there
would be questions from people from
different backgrounds who might be
interested in this so in that picture
the art RCA thing of the local what was
that material
it was tungsten on the cathode and
nickel on the anode with his clever
bellows compression seal very simple
structure they didn't put cesium in it
but they did get a vacuum and it was
only four and a half percent but you
know it's pretty pretty cool yeah of
course you got to have the torch and if
you look at the energy you know it's not
not a necessarily ideal situation so
well I don't know flame there's actually
people at Lawrence Berkeley Lab ores is
sort of a combustion group and there's
another National Lab people that really
know about combustors your combustor in
the natural in your water heater is not
designed for thermionic s'right it would
have to be re thought to get a more
radiant heat would help heat transfer is
a big deal and I guess the candle I
don't know quite what the flame would be
it's a lot lower than that torch and the
the that would drive the cathode work
function down it would drive the anode
work function is you know gonna have to
go even lower so you sort of get in this
limbo situation so it really works I
would think that a thermoelectric
thermic tandem would be a really neat
thing and we have a world leader in
photovoltaics here how would this is
there a mix where where this sort of
thing could be
useful in conjunction with photovoltaics
I guess the the game-changer is that it
isn't a the the applications focusing on
something that would be consumer
relatively low power you could tile them
up to get a lot of power and there would
be some challenges in that but I think
there could be applications getting rid
of batteries is a a good thing Japan had
a large project on eliminating batteries
in the that would be supplying ten to a
hundred watts because they are dangerous
right you would have battery fires as a
problem Boeing 787 has a lot of
batteries and they catch on fire right
it's but if you replaced it with a
fossil fuel thermionic battery
equivalent these little applications are
not going to contribute epsilon to
global warming right and they may
contribute a lot to getting the
reduction of the the logistics trail of
building batteries is also something
that you know once you have the battery
it's great but you may need to rip up a
lot of stuff and invest a lot of energy
to get that you know the refining
everything it's a very simple thing that
maybe yeah and if you could really work
on it I guess my the lithium polymer
batteries that we actually use in
engineering 40m lab which Mark Horowitz
has created this course I don't know if
any of you have intersected with it as
students or TAS or section leaders but
the first lab is a solar-powered cell
phone charger and the battery is a
lithium polymer battery and they're a
little you know they're getting better
but those are the batteries that are you
can't fly with they won't even fly them
on cargo planes they have to be shipped
and they have a tendency when they drop
to become unstable my dad is a retired
EE and model airplane fishing auto and
he had a crash
a couple of years ago got the battery
out of the plane you know walking back
on this field and one of his friends
said hey your jackets on fire
I think cut caught fire in his jacket
and and lithium got it off quickly but
it's something that we know how to
handle a little bits of fossil fuels and
if you can beat them on efficiency then
you have something safer some people
want to have highways in the sky with
UAVs delivering pizzas and other things
to dorm rooms and and if there's ever
that kind of density of traffic with
battery-powered operation you another
possibility actually in our lab we got a
fire can for the lipo batteries because
you can't put them out with a fire
extinguisher we have a metal dust pan
too you know scoop those lipo batteries
get them in the can and let them burn
out it's uh they'll do something in
there and you know open it up possibly
with a chemical suit you know breathing
apparatus it's there they're you know
fairly unoptimized refor this so the
question of could you actually go direct
to electricity and get rid of the Tesla
and have this good old Tesla pulse up to
the gas tank yeah yeah but you don't
have any internal combustion engine you
have a torch and they make it they sound
cool but the you know it's in principle
that was an early you know to notice
Bosch is on there they make water
heaters in Europe and they do make a lot
of automotive systems I think the the
thermionic engine you have a century of
development and in really efficient ways
in principle you might be able to do a
bit better but it's probably better to
fly you know would be you know is where
weight matters and this could be
an advantage it's not in that case say I
you know it'd be interesting to look at
the lifecycle of a the Tesla battery
pack and you know and view that against
something you know it could be that
opportunity is maybe just general hybrid
cars where you're gonna be running an
engine and it unless you're braking
you're not doing any regeneration so you
get rid of the internal combustion
engine well just there's the waste heat
from the internal combustion engine to
charge the battery as opposed to
recharging it better when you're just so
the waste heat of it of an engine is not
that hot the the thermal electrics might
get up to temperatures where you could
implement that thermionic we have to get
hotter and so what you really need is a
combustor that would be more like your
water here to go you know that hot to go
direct to electricity and and their
issues with emissions if you are at
those high temperatures
you know you well it's yeah it is you
know you could say it definitely there's
sources of heat that you might in the
future be able to engineer the work
functions and get some significant on
electricity out of so so it's a long
march right now the fusion people are on
a longer it is not a typical
quick turn software consumer sort of
thing so the Department energy is
stepping up to invest in energy startups
and Stanford did pretty well they aren't
all hard core you know technologies a
lot to do in energy with software
married to existing infrastructure and
and so I those that are on the verge of
getting out or forming startups you
might want to have a run at this year's
cyclotron Road you do have to go to
Berkeley and hang out up there red is
not the official color of the
institution it's in West Berkeley though
so you can live in the city and counter
commute and yeah so so I think it is a
start on complimenting the venture
capital of reducing the risk and maybe
getting some
technology that could go up the learning
curve and make a major impact and carbon
and efficiency cool yeah so questions
from the audience how many of you are
e's other engineer well yeah they're
other engineering okay this is EE 380
right but I
so I'm GE 412 which is advanced Nanofab
and we have a mixture of people even
outside engineering that would be into
Nanofab it breakthroughs in surface
science are highly relevant to
understanding these effects to a degree
that was inconceivable even 20 or 30
years ago so the I think the progress
could be quite successful and I
mentioned the guy in Germany who is
pushing hard there's a European wide
project inspired directly from the
Stanford photon enhanced thermionic
project the in Asia you would have
individual faculty in China who are
pursuing this there's a lot of great
cathode work in Beijing they have
recently collaborated with slack on
cathodes not for this but for other
things so it's not like you're starting
from zero in fact we are building on a
tremendous amount of investment and
maybe it will finally pay off in a new
century so
I'll sit not thank you very much for
your attention
you